le 6 novembre prochain la télévision
présente dans ce genre vous qu'il avait
réalisé quel est l'esprit que vous venez
dans cette réalisation
si j'avais à mettre en scène la vie de
molière je dis la chose suivante un
homme de 40 ans arrive à paris plein
d'idées bouillonnant après 20 ans de vie
dans les tournées théâtrales miteuse
ayant envie de dire et de bien dire puis
ça marche
il fait le tartuffe un scandale qui fait
donc je pense ainsi ce temps là les
normes à scandales tels que la pièce a
été interdite sous sa forme primitive la
sienne pendant 250 ont juste la moitié
du siècle dernier
je crois qu dont j'en étais vraiment
compris dans les cercles universitaires
et par la critique
je crois que don juan est tout sauf une
histoire d'hommes et femmes
c'est une histoire entre la connaissent
à dieu est un homme arrivé au bout de
son expérience et de sa grandeur
je crois donc dont jouiraient
contemporain dans le sens précis où
notre époque et préoccupe
essentiellement du destin de l'homme et
ce qu'il fait l'énorme talent énorme
génie de molière c'est d'avoir été ce à
trois siècles avant nous de qui c'est la
préoccupation constante bien alors au
siècle dernier on condamnait donc je la
moralité ce qu'elles étaient il fallait
condamner donc gens je suis intimement
persuadé que la représentation initiale
dans la représentation initial dont j'en
avais la sympathie de monier d'où le
scandale en chef je me suis dit qu'il
fallait déshabiller je crois que pour
les gens molière à la télévision souvent
théâtre mais il ya un phénomène
théâtrale prévisions ne possède pas
c'est de la perruque et les mots
difficilement perceptible difficilement
compréhensible alors j'ai décidé
d'enlever la perruque
j'avais dont juin puisqu'elle est un peu
chaud il aime bien est un peu chaud vous
faites pas d'illusion c'est pas un
problème pour lui c'est quoi j'entame je
voulais ce donjon comme ça mais je ne
voulais pas moderne je voulais pas en
smoking je ne voulais pas actualisés
terme aux rives dont jean il fallait le
thé temporalité c'est donc avec un mari
marchand choisi des costumes fussent
hors du temps à vrai dire il se
rapproche un petit peu les costumes
10830 dont j'estime que c'est la
meilleure époque de
représentation du phénomène d'anjouan et
de son épouse et promettez un divan du
psy fait rien ce sera paul byron d'un
certain nombre de grands problèmes
romantically bien je vais donc
déshabille d'autre part j'ai demandé et
on m'a accordée non merci ceux qui
meurent accordé j'ai demandé à tourner
donc jouer non pas en décor reconstruire
studio mur d'écrans naturel pourquoi
pour retrouver à la télévision cette
chose admirable qui est la distance
théâtrale quand un comédien monte sur
les planches c'est tout de suite
merveilleux parce qu'il est sur les
planches parce qu'il domine le public
parce que le message pour employer un
mot à la mode
le message qu'il dispense est dispensé
dans le public est réuni là pour
l'entendre un télévision on est devant
le poste
il fallait retrouver cette distance
essayer de la retrouver je crois qu'à la
télévision quand on fait du décor
stylisé théâtral on accommode à la sauce
théâtre mais c'est pas le théâtre j'ai
essayé de retrouver dans la réalité des
décors encore plus théâtraux ceux du
théâtre
c'est pourquoi je vais tourner par
exemple aux salines de chaud dans un
décor de nicolas ledoux qui est célèbre
du xviiie siècle c'est pourquoi j'ai
tourné dans un grand hôtel vide parce
que don joindre avant tout un voyageur
il se fixe pas c'est pourquoi j'ai
tourné vraiment au bord de la mer
puisque la pièce m'offrez cette
possibilité merveilleuse d'être la seule
pièce de molière qui ne se déroule pas
dans les salons
alors j'ai dans les avis et les
personnages j'ai donc essayé de
retrouver une distance théâtrale par des
décors n'ont pas démesuré mais qui
expliqua les personnages par l'intérieur
ce qu'il disait eh ben on a fait le film
dont on pas un phénomène qui m'a
intéressé dans le choix des personnages
daujan s'il avait été classique mambo
classiquement jeunes classiquement
triomphant et bien ça n'aurait pas été
monde en juin ce qui est extraordinaire
dans le phénomène de domjean c'est qu'il
plaise et la racine de ce du fait de
plaire est inconnaissable sans doute
dongeois ne sait pas lui-même qu'il
plaît et pourquoi il sait qu'il plaît il
peut pas s'en empêcher
mais ne sais pas pourquoi c'est pourquoi
un don jouant qu'on peut supposer boas
aurait été une explication logique du
fait qu'il plaît et c'est fish et tout
par terre
c'est pourquoi il fallait un personnage
qui sans être beau fut ce qu'on appelle
communément dans la vie un donjon ou qui
semble à l'être et puis cody est à
l'heure actuelle suprêmement ça vous ai
dit tout à l'heure que pour moi dont je
n'étais pas une histoire entre hommes et
femmes entre donjons et les femmes c'est
vrai c'est vrai en ce sens que il a
dépassé ses terres le fait qu'ils ne
sachent pas pourquoi il plaît mais qu'il
ait besoin de faire parce que quand on
aime ça ça se développe il est il est
passé au delà de ça pour moi il est mort
au début tu lis c'est qui va mourir
ça pourrait s'appeler requiem pour dont
joue en fait et il le sait et il est
allé au bout de ce que l'homme peut
faire c'est pourquoi il a dépassé le
viril a dépassé son frère quand ces gens
là viennent le voir il est regardé les
répond même pensé produit souvent la
question de savoir pourquoi les longs
monologues d'elvire de don carlos parce
que don jouant les regarde
il les regarde longuement et pu seul
l'intérêt ce même pas répondu répond à
la fin par une petite phrase courte
parra qui assassinent les gens il a
dépassé ce stade c'est l'homme dans
toute sa grandeur est l'homme qui est
allé très loin
et puis un jour au troisième acte avec
la statue du commandeur il rencontre
l'inconnaissable enfin ce qui
esthétiquement molière qui était un
libertin sens du xviie siècle c'est à
dire non pas un non croyant mais un
incroyant esthétiquement l'histoire
apparu bella molière alors il l'a prise
pour ce qu'elle est il a donc mis dans
la pièce l'inconnaissable et la grandeur
de molière c'est d'avoir fait répondre
non
bonjour dit non il y je ne sais pas ce
que c'est ça existe peut-être mais je
dirais non parce que je suis un homme
et quand le combat devient énorme qu'à
la fin ils se sont coincés parce que
c'est un homme coincé et bien au lieu
d'accepter
il va pratiquement aller à la mort
peut-être molière ne sont en est il pas
absolument compte au moment où il l'a
écrit mais pratiquement il ya une
délibération volontaire de la part de
domjean d'aller pratiquement et ça peut
difficilement se traduire au théâtre
parce que le théâtre est un lieu
scénique les orienter bien une verdon
joint ce cinquième acte de donjon est
très difficile à mettre en scène parce
qu'il est court il est tout à fait court
il ya la scène de l'hypocrisie puis la
mort à la télévision j'ai pu rendre
compte de cette volonté d'aller au
devant de l'inéluctable c'est à dire que
don juan va vers le commandeur licou
yves à cheval l'ivac et il est
interrompu par don carlos il élimine don
carlo s'ils continuent il est interrompu
par le spectre de la mort il élimine
respecte de la mort ils valent aux
commandeurs il tombe et meurt alors en
fait le personnage de don juan dépasse
considérablement les femmes mais mais
mais il dit lui même qu'il les haines et
qu'il les aime au moment où ils laissés
nus c'est pourquoi j'ai alors là c'est
peut-être là dessus que ça va chauffer
beaucoup les gens mon ticket ya le
deuxième est le deuxième acte
traditionnellement c'est une scène où
dont jean est aux prises avec de petites
paysannes et les séduit mais les en
geôle
en fait les anges vraiment
c'est parfois par très jolie parce que
ça confine au jeu demain ses
traditionnels pourquoi parce que la
critique parce que la morale
traditionnelle du siècle dernier voulait
que dongeois en flux condamné donc il
fallait que tu fus l'est dans un certain
sens moi j'ai pas voulu ça j'ai voulu
que chasseur et chasser piégeurs et
piégés
il aime cette petite paysanne au moment
où il a rencontré d'ailleurs il lui
propose le bon motif et chaque fois
c'est à la fois un jeu qu'il fait et
c'est peut-être vrai en définitive il
aime il était mais c'est une scène de
vrais amoureux
c'est tristan et iseult jeu les traiter
comme ça sur cette grande plage avec ses
nuages qui passent cette mère qui bat
dans le silence le plus total
en définitive le deuxième axe est la
dernière fois et donc dans le sait car
pour moi les condamnés au départ c'est
la dernière fois qu'il aura la chance
l'opportunité et mais des mets 5 minutes
et qu'elle aime alors en le sachant il
va la convaincre de l'emi lui et va
l'aimer bronzé et puis quand la rame et
à la fin du deuxième acte revient qu'on
le poursuit l'un le monde rendent chez
le monde dans sa réalité dans le son
opération la leçon réel revient le monde
entier retombe sur ses épaules et la
pièce commence vraiment et derrière à la
fin de la contrôle commandera ce qui
fait que en fait pour moi le personnage
de charlotte prend une grande importance
il est comme on dit chez nous en ligne a
h1n1 pour deux lignes on m'ignore trop
aussi important que celui de nuire
on ne parle jamais du rôle des devis
charlotte ça n'est pas pour moi une
coquette c'est une amoureuse voilà en
gros ce que je voulais vous dire moi sur
ma conception du personnage dont je vais
envoyer qu'elle est assez elle est à la
fois assez traditionnel par rapport à la
nouvelle
enfin à des mises en scène déjà fait et
surtout au théâtre mais j'ai essayé de
dépasser complètement le stade de de la
confidence à quelques milliers de
personnes qui vont au théâtre j'ai
essayé que vraiment ce qu'a dit molière
fut compris par beaucoup de personnes et
que la seule manière de faire vraiment
comprendre les choses aux gens c'est la
poésie c'est à dire le contact direct
intuitif avec les personnages pas la
littérature
alors j'ai essayé de le faire j'ai
essayé de le faire comme je voulais dit
en fait en essayant surtout et avant
tout de ne pas faire une mise en scène
archéologiques
car l'archéologie en définitive c'est
l'école des chartes de la mise en scène
c'est le choix d'une perruque qui devait
être celle que molière portait au moment
où la pièce a été représentée ça
vraiment j'ai peur